we've been wondering whether republicans
in the house of representatives and in
the senate
are ever going to denounce these
outrageous new members of congress we're
talking about people like
marjorie taylor greene lauren bobert
madison cawthorne or are republicans
going to be supportive of these new
radicals
or are establishment republicans going
to avoid talking about them all together
and we're going to look through two
examples
today we have our first example and it's
a really good one this is
steve scalise steve scalise is a
republican congressman
also the house minority whip and he was
on fox news yesterday morning and he was
asked about comments
made by congresswoman marjorie taylor
green
and somehow he was able to abort that
question
and talk about joe biden
china and carbon it sounds like
this couldn't possibly happen but it's
exactly what happened let's take a look
at the video clip
marjorie taylor green the freshman
congresswoman from georgia
under some fire for past comments i'm
going to be meeting with
majority minority leader kevin mccarthy
later and
liz cheney is going to have to talk to
some of her members
on the republican side who would like to
see her
removed from her leadership position
because of supporting impeachment and
voting for that
based on your conversations are more of
your members supportive
of green or cheney well first of all
i've rejected those statements
by marjorie and you know i think uh
we're going to be talking tomorrow in
conference we're going to have an
in-person meeting
uh you know in in the capitol where
we're going to be talking through a lot
of these issues internally
look first of all we're very united in
our opposition to the devastating
economic hits that president
biden has been doing in his first two
weeks the paris accord we haven't even
talked about
will crush american manufacturing and
send it to china
where they emit five times more carbon
to make things like steel that
pennsylvania will not be able to make
if they get that so we're going to be
talking about all those things
steve scalise is a horrible ideologue
but he's also
somewhat of a realist and he does seem
to realize that marjorie taylor green
is bonkers i mean just cuckoo but he
still manages to pivot
on a question about marjorie taylor
green and talk about chinese carbon and
joe biden
and it's just out of this world what do
you think about marjory taylor green
he talks about carbon and there's
a difficulty here for republicans
because
until it's clear otherwise they have to
assume
that the types of people who support
marjorie taylor green are an important
part of the electorate
to the republican party they have to
assume until it's proven otherwise
that a lot of the supporters and voters
of marjory taylor green
all are are also the types of people
that uh
people like steve scalise need to
continue uh um
getting support from and i'm not saying
that scalise would otherwise denounce
marjorie taylor green
but he must be aware of the fact that
denouncing her straight up
might not play well with the portion of
the voters that he and his party need
and in the end failure to act is a form
of consent
um and all of these republicans who no
doubt will
fail to do a damn thing about these
outrageous radicals that got voted in
during the last election
are complicit but they are trying to
sort of thread a needle
to avoid consequences as much as
possible for the republican party and
for themselves that's all they're doing
you know we talked earlier about newsmax
now doesn't want anybody talking about
dominion voting systems and they
tried to kick off my pillow guy mike
lindell when he wanted to talk about
dominion voting systems
newsmax has not all of a sudden found uh
decided that the truth is important
newsmax has not all of a sudden decided
that journal journalistic ethics matter
to them these things are financial
pragmatic calculations and it's the
exact same thing with with steve scalise
and
case in point the further we get from
january 6th
without accountability the more and more
that republicans like steve scalise are
going to be able to just opt out of
condemning
the people who were most responsible in
the republican party
for inciting that riot which certainly
includes donald trump at the top of the
party
but uh increasingly also includes people
like marjorie taylor greene and lauren
bobert you know after the access
hollywood tape
some of them claimed to be outraged but
then they weren't anymore and then
you know just months ago when kelly
leffler was asked about that tape
she was able to get away with saying i
don't even know what you're talking
about i've never seen that tape i don't
know a thing about it
and um the the sort of last thing before
we move on to the next clip here
is we've been looking at a lot of
interviews over the last few days that
republicans have given
on cnn fox news newsmax
oan etc notice the complete lack of
policy platform
in the republican party right now yeah i
know that that's been the case for a
while
in some bigger picture sense that it's
been a lot about just
prevent democrats from doing stuff but
right now
there is a completely uh
they're they're not even pretending to
care about policy they say
joe biden is doing too many executive
orders they
say where are we going to get the money
for all of this stuff that joe biden
wants to do with the coveted stimulus
1.9 trillion dollar package
and they say why hasn't joe biden more
quickly dealt with the virus even though
he's only been in office for two weeks
there is a they aren't even pretending
to have
actual policy proposals of any kind with
the exception
of that pathetically small stimulus
package
that they are proposing as an
alternative to joe biden's it's about
being anti-biden
it's about being anti-democrats and it's
about um
a pr essentially at this point and if
they had fought the virus
with half the conviction that they've
been using over the last 14 days to
fight joe biden
we would be much better off in this
country we would have had far fewer
coveted deaths in this country but sadly
that's never been their priority
let's now look at another example of a
republican confronted with the comments
of marjorie taylor green
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor
i'm thrilled about because i sleep on a
helix mattress
at home and it's just the perfect
mattress one of the best things about
helix is
you don't have to guess which mattress
do i need which one will be good for me
you take their famous sleep quiz on
their website you tell them your body
type
your sleeping position your back pain
issues you might have
and they will pair you with a mattress
that will be perfect for you
i took the sleep quiz the mattress they
suggested was exactly what i needed
i often get too hot at night the
mattress keeps me cool
it's not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right
and i've just been getting way better
sleep you only buy a mattress
every decade or so don't get stuck with
something that's not perfect for you and
all helix mattresses come with a 10-year
warranty and they'll even come to your
house and pick it up within a hundred
days
if you don't love it but i think you
will all of my viewers will get up to
200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video